enfin je cherche quelqu'un benjamin
castaldi l'est ou baltes ou pas aller me
chercher banana castaldi qui fait ça si
là
[Applaudissements]
ah ça les gars c'est le retour du tout
était prêt à le regarder chez vous il a
détecté une magnifique
oui oui au soir c'est les soucis
[Applaudissements]
monsieur catalyser le code normal chez
domino c'est bien c'est sûr à mes tubes
et merci saleh monsieur je sois là quoi
arusha rochard d'accord très bien merci
disant bon soir j'avoue faire d'abord je
vous faire bible and test et on invente
et au regard des barrettes e vo mais
quoi je suis venu protéger à poté dont
tu délires citoyen quelque chose voilà
je risque rien non bah non gardé ah mais
moi je suis de villa noonan
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas là alors est ce que tu peux faire à
ce que tu veux à la présentation mes
chroniques je ne sais pas si la réponse
est non je suis pas d'accord alors
jusqu'à ce que je me propose et on food
a déconné l'émission
voilà les cachottiers caduque si ça
suffira pour la jeune avec le pluriel
merci à manico l'applaudir
[Applaudissements]